if you and your classmates were suddenly
dying in gruesome ways due to a
horrifying curse what would you do you
don't know how to stop this curse and
it's only a matter of time till it's
your turn to die i'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do and
how to beat the curse in another this
kid is about to get everyone killed
koichi is not your average youngster who
wakes up in the hospital after a
collapsed lung and prepares for his new
life staying in yomiyama city and this
is no ordinary city a few school
classmates from koichi's new school came
a visit at the hospital eerily
introducing themselves as 9th grade
students in class 3. little does koichi
know that this class 3 will cost him
everything he loves in the coming months
the three students redhead girl tall kid
and this glasses girl grill koichi left
and right and pry a little too much into
his personal life from asking where he
came from why he's here and how long
he's been here for something is not
right and koichi does his best to answer
all of their strange questions now to
realizing that they're just doing their
job to prevent the most horrifying curse
from reappearing again he's unaware that
he will soon be the cause for countless
deaths they shake hands and redhead girl
asks koichi a final time if he's ever
lived in this town before and then
suddenly leaves koichi without uttering
a word okay this is super weird and
frankly i'm uncomfortable as hell
students from a class i've never been to
start showing up to meet me is either
really sweet or really creepy and the
fact that they were so intent on knowing
if i've lived here before makes me think
that they care way too much about who i
am i don't even know them now this being
1997 means that we have no internet so i
can't stalk them on facebook or anything
however what i would do is look into the
school itself either from old newspapers
or from word of mouth because if these
three students are as weird as hell then
that probably means that the rest of the
school was indoctrinated by the rest of
them in the same way and looking into
the swords the school itself would allow
me to gain some context into why they
were so concerned with my situation
because there must be a reason for it
100 push-ups 100 sit-ups 100 squats and
10 kilometer runs have you also started
your journey to become the strongest but
now you're losing your hair what do you
do well you get keeps of course keeps is
a subscription service that makes it
easier and more affordable for men to
treat their male pattern baldness online
with online consultations with the real
doctor easy shipping and delivery right
to your door two out of three guys will
experience some type of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 so the
best way to prevent hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
some hair left keeps offers generic
versions of fda approved medications for
hair loss which makes it more affordable
their treatment typically takes between
four to six months to start seeing
results so it's important to act fast
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you can save if you're ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to keeps.com how to beat anime or click
the link below to get 50 off your first
order thank you keys for sponsoring this
video and let's get back into it a few
days later koichi heads into the
hospital lift as he sees the strangest
girl pop up right behind him carrying a
doll and startling koichi but koichi
sees that she's from the same school as
him koichi then prize into her life and
asks why she's heading to the second
basement level because the only thing
down there is the morgue the girl then
says that she's delivering something
exiting the lift before koichi finds out
that her name is mei misaki plunging
herself into the shrouded darkness as
she disappears before koichi has a
chance to ask her more questions a week
later koichi finally recovered begins
life at his new school not knowing what
hell awaits him and is introduced to the
teachers and class including miss mikami
the assistant homeroom teacher koichi
then sits down and notices mei across
the room from him the class then asks
him all sorts of questions about his
life including which part of tokyo he
came from and he sees may all of a
sudden disappear from her table almost
as if koichi never saw her in the first
place failing to grasp just what horrors
will soon plague him and everyone in
this classroom later on in the day
koichi sits out of gym class and asks
why his class class 3 doesn't have gym
class with any other members in the
school and glasses girl then says that
class 3 is different and asks more
strange questions to koichi about what
other classmates have told him about
this school but koichi just naively says
nothing blissfully unaware of the
sinister situation that he's about to be
in he then asks her if he's ever seen
misaki anywhere and that's when
everything changes glasses girl's face
draws pale and changes dramatically she
then says that she doesn't know what
he's talking about and cautiously
monitors his face knowing that he can't
find out the truth koichi then sees mae
on the building rooftop and dashes off
to see her koichi gets to the top of the
school and sees may creepily standing
watch over the town and he asks her why
she went to the second baseman the other
day may says that something very sad
happened to her but then suddenly she
changes the topic of conversation
revealing to koichi the most shocking
news of all that the entire class 3 now
associates koichi's name with death and
not just any death but a particular
death that took place at this very
school telling koichi that this school
is known for its association to death
especially his class class 3 maid then
says that koichi shouldn't try to get
close to her or to talk to her saying
that he'll find out the reasons behind
all of this soon enough leaving koichi
with more questions than answers and
nervous as hell something is definitely
going on at this school and koichi will
soon wish that he was never here to
begin with okay this school is just as
crazy as i thought and now everyone
thinks i'm some serious bad luck charm
and this strange girl mae is onto
something because if people are already
starting to ostracize me then that means
that it probably won't be long before i
start getting bullied for whatever
reason they associate me with death and
in japan i wouldn't be surprised as
bullying in japan is more common than
you think with a record number of
incidents in a single year as high as
414 thousand 378 cases from elementary
right through senior high school i'd
actually listen to mei and stay away
from her no matter if i had the hots for
her or not in fact i do the opposite and
throw a party inviting the entirety of
the class 3 to a thing at the very least
i begin to make more of an effort to get
to know everyone except mei i'd also go
to the class library and ask around
about the school death that took place
here and maybe even look into switching
classes or schools this school seems way
more creepy than i thought a few days
later koichi runs into blonde hair guy
who runs his mouth and accidentally
spills the beans that his class koichi's
class is cursed this shocks koichi and
everybody here as blonde guy just made a
huge mistake and this grabs koichi's
attention like a moth to a flame blonde
hair guy finally says that he's been
wanting to tell koichi something for a
while now but koichi suddenly sees mae
in the library and goes to chat with her
before blood hair guy gets the chance to
talk more later at night koichi pays the
hospital a visit and asks his nurse
friend if a girl died at this hospital
last monday the same day as mei first
met koichi in the left but the nurse is
not sure and thinks that there was
someone in another ward who died and
agrees to let koichi know if she finds
anything the next day red haired girl
confronts koichi during recess and asks
even more prying questions about his
life where he was born and his family
situation as red-haired girl knows she's
met koichi before but she can't pinpoint
where or when glasses girl then tries to
make redhead girl feel better but she
says as head of counter measures that
she has to do a better job she's fearful
that if she fails countless lives will
be lost in a matter of months and it's
then when koichi asks just what does a
head of countermeasures do exactly
alerting the gang even more so redhead
girl says that she's in charge of
devising and executing countermeasures
to protect the class but to protect from
what but glasses girl stops red head
girl from going into further detail just
as koichi's attention gravitates to mei
and leaves to follow her home red head
girl knows what koichi doesn't that if
she doesn't let him in on the plan soon
then everything they've worked so hard
for will get destroyed okay this school
definitely has some skeletons in their
closet and i wonder what and why did
koichi prioritize following may over
listening to redhead girl it makes sense
that if there's a girl who's head of
countermeasures then that means that she
would do everything in her power to
prevent whatever it is that is going on
in the school from happening and one of
the greatest preventative measures would
be public awareness as in letting koichi
in on whatever the hell is going on
because if he doesn't know then he won't
be able to abide by whatever
countermeasures are in place to begin
with koichi shouldn't have left as
quickly as he did but redhead should
have also explained everything to koichi
from the start koichi follows mei to a
strange dolph shop before he gets a call
from the nurse at the hospital informing
him that someone did die last monday a
junior high school girl this freaks
koichi out as the nurse tries to say the
dead girl's name the call abruptly gets
cut koichi knowing what he knows tries
to compose himself as he enters the
eerie doll shop where he meets the
strange old lady who welcomes him and
mentions that he's the first customer
today to come into the shop downstairs
he sees countless dolls seeing one that
looks just like mei and just then like a
genie in a bottle mae pops up behind him
giving him a fright something is not
right with her and she asks him if he
wants to see what's behind her eye patch
revealing to him the most puzzling thing
of all an artificial eye a doll's eye
and mentioned that her doll eye sees
things that should not be seen puzzling
koichi even further as to her creepy
nature he then mentions to her that he
heard a girl died at the hospital the
other day and asks me if she has any
sisters trying to connect her in some
way to the dead girl and may is
confusing koichi even further is mei a
ghost koichi has more questions than
answers as mei warns him not to get too
close to her may then reveals the most
horrifying thing that koichi has ever
heard she reveals to him the town curse
of class 3 26 years ago she tells him
about a student in the ninth grade who
died back then and whom the school's
teachers and classmates in a
grief-stricken state started to pretend
that she was still alive even going so
far as to acknowledge her presence in
class and pretending to include her in
the school photo and the best part about
all of this the girl who died was named
misaki mei then says that there's more
to this story but koichi is interrupted
by his grandma who demands that he comes
home this instant okay this is weird as
hell but valuable as mei just gave us a
little context into the school death
that everyone is talking about however i
wouldn't just rely on this information
from one person and if redhead or anyone
from class won't tell us anything then
i'd begin asking the people from outside
of class 3 starting with people in the
higher grades as well as look into the
school records in the library to track
down former students of the class kids
and adults alike because the one thing
we're missing right now is the whole
picture and it's clear that my situation
at the school hinges on this death from
all those years ago which means i likely
won't be able to forget about it nor get
past it until we find all the missing
pieces the next day koichi waits for the
rain to pass at the end of school and
glassesgirl then asks koichi if she
wants to walk home with her it is here
that koichi asks her the most intense
question ever and asks what mei masaki
is really like it is at this moment that
glasses girl froze terrified at the mere
thought of koichi's question she then
tells him to never speak this name in
class 3 again glasses girl shocks koichi
just as blond-haired kid interrupts them
koichi wastes no time and asks both of
them if they know of the urban legend of
class 3 from 26 years ago this question
terrifies both blond-haired kid and
glasses girl right before the homeroom
teacher comes to put a stop to their
questioning and says that it's a very
delicate issue to discuss before sending
everybody home later on koichi has had
enough of the mysteries and calls
blond-haired kid demanding that he tells
him just what the hell is going on
blonde hair kid then says that koichi
has made redhead girl the head of
countermeasures extremely angry before
telling koichi to chill and to not mess
with things that don't exist blonde
haired kid then tells koichi that he'll
explain everything next month just as
the phone gets cut off again the next
day during an exam koichi finishes early
and finds mei chilling outside and
discovers that the girl who died at the
hospital was in fact mae's cousin misaki
fujioka shocking koichi he then uses
this opportunity to pry more info from
may about what happened to class 3 26
years ago and also why does everyone in
class 3 act like may doesn't exist but
mei says to koichi that only he can see
her and this terrifies koichi at the
thought of what could possibly be
happening is mei a ghost can only he
really see her these are the questions
and more that plague koichi's mind as he
sees glasses girl running towards them
who then gets shocked at the very sight
of koichi and may before running down
the stairs in the other direction and
that will be her final mistake just then
she suddenly trips on the staircase
losing her umbrella in the process and
lands right on the umbrella itself with
the metal tip of the umbrella piercing
through the back of her neck cutting
through her like japanese butter
that's good well i must say that this is
too much of a coincidence and it's
official there's a gosh done curse up in
here and this is also why you should
never run down the stairs people always
walk because bad things can happen to
good kids now it's possible that she
could have survived if she was more
lucky provided that the umbrella merely
sliced through her muscle or connective
tissue but it doesn't seem that way as
penetrating neck injuries that take
place in or around the platysma are a
major cause of morbidity and mortality
because of the vital structures confined
to this area mainly the carotid arteries
that carry blood to the brain but it
seems like this girl didn't get too
lucky and the umbrella seemingly
punctured her larynx or windpipe now i
would suggest that we contact the girl's
family in order to notify them of her
death i really don't care i say screw
the girl and would be more interested as
to why she ran away the way she did when
she saw me and mei because does that
mean that mei is actually real that
she's not a ghost this is all a mystery
and i love every bit of it the class
looks upon the disgusting scene in shock
and horror finding out later that this
girl's mother also died in an accident
that very same day further confirming
what everyone is too scared to speak of
that the curse of class 3 is back
further sparking a series of gruesome
deaths to come starting with one person
every month it being either a student or
someone connected to the class in some
way and this means that no one is safe
later on during his checkup koichi meets
his nurse friend and they decide to get
lunch together and this is where koichi
finds out that the nurse's brother told
her that he thinks the series of deaths
were in fact not an accident koichi asks
the nurse if she knows his friend may
and that the very moment he began
talking to her these accidents started
to take place but the nurse thinks it's
just pure coincidence but we know better
and we also know that this is only the
beginning of more horrors to come koichi
also asks his nurse friend to ask her
kid brother about the events that
happened to class 3 26 years ago and
koichi is beginning to suspect that
those events and what's happening now is
linked in some way koichi then on the
way home bumps into a theater student
from school and just then this giant
glass frame nearly crushes both of them
to death and the theater kid begins to
break down as she knows that this is
only the beginning of the curse's
wretched ways well that was a close one
and now it seems like this curse is out
to get me too or maybe just this girl
maybe i could use her if i have to and
if i was koichi i would have probably
been a reverse gentleman and let her die
right here and now and taken a step back
and let gravity do its work because this
only temporarily prevented our turn to
roll with death and now who knows when
the next time death will come at our
doorstep saving her only altered what's
to inevitably come back to us like the
butterfly effect in chaos theory the
butterfly effect is the sensitive
dependence on initial conditions in
which a small change in one state of a
deterministic non-linear system can
result in large differences in a later
state meaning that this single tiny
change here is going to cause a large
consequence down the road because the
only thing that we do know at this point
is that something bad is happening
around us which means it's past time we
start recruiting some allies koichi
thinks something is definitely afoot
here and heads to the doll shop again at
the doll shop he meets may and she
mentions that the entire class and even
her think that the curse has already
begun but koichi still doesn't know what
the hell she's talking about and demands
to know once and for all everything that
she's speaking about but mei thinks it's
better that he doesn't know and leaves
him to stew in his own terrified
thoughts back at home kay talks with his
aunt who since he began his new school
has suddenly started to get headaches
and koichi discovers that his aunt 15
years ago was in the same class 3 as
koichi he asks her if the curse of class
3 was still around back then but she
says that she doesn't remember anything
koichi should have realized this sooner
this talk will cost him everything the
next day the class discusses if the
curse is truly back wondering if it's
all just a coincidence or if it's all
because of koichi they even discuss
bringing up the situation to him and if
it's too late or too dangerous now to do
anything the class then decides to treat
koichi the same way they treated mei by
pretending he doesn't exist but they
don't realize that it's already too late
to stop what's coming for them koichi
then during break finds blonde hair guy
and tells him that it's been a month and
that he now has the right to know just
what the hell is going on here but
redhead girl tells koichi to not ask any
questions just then koichi gets a phone
call from the nurse who tells him that
her brother refused to speak of what
happened to class 3 26 years ago and
that her brother also doesn't know who
the hell mei misaki was which means
either he's lying or may really doesn't
exist and it's all in koichi's head but
the call is cut short again and suddenly
the elevator breaks don't work and the
entire thing comes crashing down like a
descending coffin crushing the nurse
more so than crushed strawberries well
this is horrible this nurse lady was
really our only friend and valuable
source of information aside from may and
we can't afford to be losing friends at
a time like this but in reality there
was little chance our nurse friend could
have survived the only one possible way
would be to lay on your back in the
center of the lift as this will
distribute the force of impact over the
greatest area of your body so that no
particular part of your body is
subjected to the entire weight of any
other part of your body and even if you
did this you probably still would have
been lacerated by the debris collected
on the lift floor and no jumping right
at the last second before the lift would
have crashed would not have helped but
the good news is is that our friend
likely felt no pain in the process
meaning our nurse friend's brain was
likely too slow to realize or feel pain
or suffering at all well that's too bad
in the coming days the news of the
nurse's death plagues the school as
everyone knows but is too afraid to
speak about what is really going on the
curse of class 3 is back and it's
already begun at school the class is
deep in thought within a deep self-study
session as their homeroom teacher miss
makami is sick or so it appears koichi
decides to head to the library and dives
deep into the school records to see if
may is within the history books as he
still suspects something is off about
her but that's when he sees it his
mother in the class of 1972 yearbook
finding out that his mother was in the
very same class as him later on the
police questioned koichi about the
nurse's death concluding that her death
was indeed an accident and that the
building itself was also several decades
old but koichi knows something isn't
right koichi walks home with some
friends when they discuss the strange
disturbances that have been going on as
they say that the class has been
discussing some stuff regarding koichi
and that something very unpleasant might
happen to him very soon koichi then asks
them for a favor to get a copy of the
class roster as one of the friends ends
up feeling sorry for koichi and says
that he'll tell him everything about
what's really going on no more secrets
but just then as koichi asks the friend
if mei exists his heart suddenly starts
convulsing and the friend ends up
collapsing to the ground dead okay this
is more serious than we think as before
all we saw were coincidental deaths that
looked like accidents transpired through
outside forces but this is the first
time were seeing a death happen within
ourselves meaning unlike what went down
in final destination this curse doesn't
need to kill us in some fancy elaborate
way and can literally kill us by making
us drop dead right here right now and
what's even more strange is that
according to
worldlifeexpedency.com japan has one of
the lowest rates of coronary heart
failure with a rate of 31.5 whereas the
highest is turkmenic stat with a rating
of 379.3
and this kid dying happening right as he
tried to tell us what was really going
on this might say it's getting past
coincidental if i was koichi i test out
how on the ball this curse really is by
going in guns blazing and by that i mean
i would literally go into class 3 and
yell my lungs out about what really is
going on with this curse because so far
koichi has tried approaching this softly
but now i think it's time to go in loud
and proud also by me asking the entire
class in one go worst case more
classmates will die who offer to tell me
the truth as it seems that way based on
my last friend who died right before he
told me best case at least someone will
finally cave in and let me in on what's
really going on like i said class 3
following the rules will only work if
everyone is in the know which that alone
makes it practically foolish and
impractical as to why they haven't let
me end fully on what's going on when
their survival also depends on my
actions as well since i'm also in class
3. it seems like 87 are you enough
subscribe so help us with the algorithm
and subscribe now the class mourns yet
another death as koichi soon begins to
find out that it's official the class
has begun to pretend that he doesn't
exist ignoring his questions and his
efforts in grabbing their attention he's
becoming just like mei after school
koichi gets a note of the class roster
which leads him to head straight to may
he tells her of the student who died and
that the class has started to ignore him
but now koichi's thoughts on may as a
ghost finally dissipate realizing that
the class was simply ignoring her the
whole time we also find out that mae
lives right above the doll shop as her
mom owns the shop and is the creepy
reason why so many of the dolls look
like her how adorable mae then finally
decides to catch him a break and she
decides to spill the beans on the whole
curse saying that the masaki who died 26
years ago was the triggering event that
began this curse in the first place from
then on drawing class 3 closer to death
beginning the year after misaki's
classmates graduated from class 3
causing a nearly yearly cycle that
begins with one student dying each month
once the curse begins beginning only
when the total number of students within
class 3 increases by one person but the
class has never been able to figure out
who the extra person was 25 years ago
shortly after the new term began they
realized they were short one desk and
one chair even though they had prepared
enough for every student and checking
the school records were pointless as
they are constantly altered with
everyone's memories being wiped out each
time this happens and may then reveals
the most shocking thing of all the extra
person in class is dead but doesn't know
they are already dead and are made of
flesh and bone just like the rest of
everybody else but until they find out
who the extra dead classmate is people
will keep dying because of what class 3
did 26 years ago by ignoring a dead
student this is the reason why they are
known as a place that invites the dead
this is why the class has counter
measures in place to help the class try
and escape this curse and why they have
redhead girl as head of counter measures
and the reason why the class pretends
that only one person in class doesn't
exist to make up for the extra student
by ignoring one in class
okay this is actually insane if i was
koichi i would see if there was a
history of anyone switching classes from
class 3 into another class because that
would definitely be on the records and
we could see for ourselves to what
degree of separation does this curse
affect us and this includes trying to
see if it would be possible to eliminate
the class entirely thereby moving all
students to the rest of the other
classes effectively increasing all the
class numbers by an extra few students
granted this may not work but i don't
see anyone else doing anything other
than following whatever rules they are
following right now which are obviously
not stopping this curse from still
killing people so we might as well try
something new as the curse progresses
the teachers become more vigilant and
cautious about the whole situation
warning the class not to tell any
outsiders later koichi then goes to mace
house again and may lets koichi know
that she knows who the extra person is
but just as she's about to say it her
mom enters and spoils the gang's
investigation forcing them to take their
talk outside and koichi finds out that
the class decided to brilliantly bolster
security measures by pretending that two
people don't exist now him and mei the
next day they meet in the library and
they find out that the librarian has
been here since the start and he was
class three's homeroom teacher way back
and he lets them in further on how the
curse works he says that the ones in
most danger are either the related
family members of the students if not
the students themselves and only towards
people who live in this town and that
the curse gets weaker the further you go
out of town the librarian then shows
them the history of class rosters from
when the curse began up until now
telling them that when the curse is
active it mysteriously alters the
records and the people's memories of
everything including the deceased
revealing that there's no way to beat
this curse other than pretending someone
in class 3 doesn't exist that is if they
can handle being mistreated this way all
seems lost until the next day the
teacher walks in places a bag on his
desk and then all of a sudden brings out
a knife and plunges it into his neck
right in front of everyone well this is
next level insanity this is just gone
from people dying in mysterious
accidents to full on stabbing themselves
first it was the kid with the heart
attack and now people are willingly
taking their own life in public at this
point i don't even think only class 3
could be talking about this curse i
would imagine a teacher killing
themselves during school time would not
only alert the entire school but also
the local news and this would result
into more inquiries into class 3 and
honestly this is our best bet because no
one seems to talk about this curse with
people outside of the class but this
could be our best chance in letting
people on the outside to help us or at
the very least report on it so we could
get some differing opinions on what the
hell is really going on it was beyond
foolish to not let anyone else in on the
situation all this time the teacher's
withered corpse lays in front of
everybody forcing the class to evacuate
and wait for what's to come the police
also find even more disturbing evidence
that the teacher not only lived with his
mother but killed her leaving her body
to rot inside their home later redhead
girl talks to koichi that people will
blame him as well as her for everything
that's happened but she thinks that this
is only the beginning and sadly she's
right on the money later koichi and may
go and talk to the librarian about the
only time the curse stopped mid-year 25
years ago when the class went on a trip
to somewhere somehow mysteriously
causing the curse to stop mid-august and
they even visited a shrine discussing if
this has something to do with stopping
the curse or if it's all a coincidence
but this doesn't stop the school from
announcing that the class will soon be
conducting the very same trip in the
coming month of august hoping to repeat
what happened all those years ago later
koichi gets a call from blonde hair kid
asking him to come to a restaurant where
he also finds redhead girl at the
restaurant redhead girl again swears
she's met koichi before but is
coincidentally distracted just as
blond-haired kid shows up late it is
here where the waitress tells one of
them that one of her regulars was also
in class 3 years ago and claims to have
stopped the curse himself claiming that
he left a hint somewhere to help the
future generation stop the curse but he
can't remember where but they don't know
how to find him until they find out that
this guy was his aunt's classmate okay
if this guy supposedly saved class 3 all
those years ago and even hit a clue on
how to beat this curse then it is
possible that he could have also told
others about how to beat it which could
result in others also taking it upon
themselves to leave a clue somewhere but
the infuriating problem is is that no
one remembers much of anything if i was
them i would begin questioning each
member of class 3 from the past and the
information is available in the library
and this way we could get a better
picture by questioning all the past
class 3 members now no one may remember
much but we might get something but we
won't know until we ask it is highly
unlikely that with how seriously class 3
takes this curse that no one in all of
these years wouldn't have tried to leave
some sort of valuable information behind
for future generations to find even if
the information was helpful or not
koichi then at home asks his aunt more
about this guy and the class trip that
everyone took but his aunt can't seem to
coincidentally remember much but agrees
to help talk to him with koichi the next
day the gang decides to arrange a trip
to the beach to meet this guy and this
black-haired kid even joined them but
that was his biggest mistake the class
and a sick classmate along with the aunt
head to the beach just as the mystery
man who supposedly stopped the curse all
those years ago shows up but he can't
seem to remember a damn thing only that
he left a clue somewhere at the school
just then a massive wind picks up the
gang's ball and throws it into the ocean
and this black-haired kid the guy who is
puking the whole ride here offers to get
the ball not realizing that he'll never
come back to shore alive this
black-haired kid then swims out into the
sea chasing after the ball only he
slowly stops swimming and the view of
his body in the distance becomes faint
koichi and the gang tense up in fear of
the worst but just then his head pops up
showing that all is fine and is
continuing to get the ball until he
faints again koichi and the gang
frantically tried to get to him but just
then notice a boat heading right for
black-haired kid the boat rams right
through him tearing his corpse into
pieces bloodying up the water the
shocked group stands knee-deep in water
paralyzed with fear right as the claimed
savior for class 3 this guy utters in
shock that he left a hint in the
classroom leaving a tape somewhere
behind that's where they need to look to
find out how to stop this curse oh my
gosh this was insane and this kid died
way too quickly and no i'm not talking
about getting ripped apart by the boat
i'm talking about drowning there's
nothing like the feeling of being
helpless at sea with no sense of
direction getting submerged further and
further into the depths by cascading
waves forcing you to with all of your
might try and swim upward exhausting
your entire body until you can barely
reach the surface forcing your mouth to
gape wide open and finally inhale the
salt water and you slowly lose
consciousness fun fact did you know that
drowning is actually the third leading
cause of unintentional injury death
globally with an estimated 236 annual
drowning deaths worldwide with children
and males being the greatest at risk the
only thing that kid could have done was
to stop swimming and to not exhaust
himself trying to fight the current and
then he needs to identify any such rip
currents and he needs to swim parallel
to the shore to get out of the rip
current's path by looking to swim toward
the direction of the nearest brake waves
marking the end of the rip current but
let's be honest with this curse going
around there's little chance he wasn't
already dead that day to begin with
later back in yomiyama city the gang
finds out the most horrifying thing that
the event that led to black-haired kids
death actually took place in the cursed
town itself he hit his head at home and
caused a cerebral contusion within his
brain to form right before he left for
the beach this means that no one in this
town is safe and anyone could be next
koichi knows that time is running out
and talks with blond-haired kid telling
him to not tell anyone that he thinks
that the tape is hidden somewhere in the
classroom agreeing to meet up tomorrow
at the school to look for it the next
day mae finds out that koichi and the
group are planning to look for the tape
and agrees to join them they scour
through the closed off floor and search
through the numerous classrooms there in
another part of town the kid from acting
class tells her friend that her family
is planning to leave town for good and
she bids her friends goodbye not
realizing that this carefree attitude
will lead to her death back at the
school the group finally finds the tape
taped behind a locker they quickly put
it inside a tape recorder and begin to
hear what will only shock them further
on the tape they hear the adult the
friend of koichi's aunt we met earlier
who goes into depth of what happened all
those years ago and how he beat the
terrible curse he says that his class
left for a trip out of town to pay
respects to a shrine that they hoped
would help stop the curse cleaning it up
in the process but they learned that
this tactic was useless and this leads
to two of their members dying as they
went down the hill from the shrine with
one dying of a lightning strike and one
falling off of the cliff entirely but
just then in the midst of the tape's
recording a teacher walks in forcing the
gang to hide resulting in the tape
getting wrecked not getting to hear the
most important part but one of the
classmates agrees to try and fix it and
so the gang waits okay this was all
types of bad to begin with your best bet
during a lightning storm is to get off
of any hill or high ground immediately
now that thunderstorm was insane and
likely violated the 30 rule which is a
rule used for thunderstorms counting to
30 the moment you see a lightning strike
and if you hear thunder before the
30-second count is up then that means
the thunderstorm is close enough to be
dangerous which in this case it clearly
was now the gang wasn't near any proper
shelter so their best bet in that case
would be to stop running and go fetal
and by that i mean curling up into a
ball with your head tucked in and your
hands over your ears minimizing your
contact with the ground and being as low
as humanly possible they also would have
done better to stay away from isolated
trees and bodies of water trying to run
during a lightning storm was probably
the worst thing they could have done
elsewhere we see the same kid from drama
class the one who met up with koichi die
as the family car gets hit with a
falling rock causing the entire car to
derail and run off the road killing
everybody inside the day of the fateful
class trip outside of town arrives and
the gang takes up room at this giant
mansion little do they know that by the
end of this almost all of them will die
the group also finally fixes the tape
and wastes no time in hearing the last
bit of it the man who stopped the curse
all those years ago continues to recount
the story and says that once they came
down from the mountain he got into a
fight with another mysterious student
and whom he ended up accidentally
killing in the process the strangest
thing was that by the next morning the
body was gone reading any evidence of
what had taken place and on top of that
everyone from his class didn't even know
who he was talking about it's almost as
if they had their memories wiped and the
class roster even revealed 19 students
on the trip not 20 meaning this man
accidentally killed the extra student
and ended the curse in the process the
group now knows what to do they need to
find the extra student and kill them to
stop the curse only there's no way to
tell the living from the dead and to top
it all off the extra person doesn't even
know they are dead which means they need
to create a plan to sift through all of
the other students and find the dead
person later at dinner a tense air
arises as everyone sits on edge knowing
that one of them will be next and they
are right just then one of the students
starts choking finding out that he has
asthma but he has used up his inhaler
resulting in the librarian to drive him
to the hospital this is it folks it's
show time this curse is literally about
to kill everyone which means i stand a
better chance of surviving if i
eliminate everyone else there's little
chance that at this point we'll find the
students so i would begin to take
matters into my own hands first up i
would round up a few students that i
know i could control specifically
redhead girl and i would begin killing
all of the students after dinner killing
them in their own rooms as they rest by
working together with one or two members
to stab slit puncture choke smother and
basically kill every student in the
hotel which wouldn't be hard since it's
mostly filled with unsuspecting students
anyways then after the deed is done i
would find the remaining members and
congratulate them for helping me with my
plan and when they're least suspecting
it i would kill them too which would
ultimately cover my bases in finding out
who the extra person is mae later in the
room confesses to koichi that her cousin
is in fact her twin sister revealing
that it was her that she was visiting in
the hospital on that night when she
first met koichi but that's not all may
also then finally reveals something even
more insane she reveals that her
artificial doll eye can see the dead and
the living she can tell when someone is
about to die and this is the reason that
she keeps it covered koichi is shocked
and asks her if she knows who the dead
extra person is but just then
blond-haired kid busts into the room
saying that he messed up and
accidentally killed a student in other
parts of the hotel redhead girl
discusses with this glasses girl about
may and suspect that she is in fact the
extra person because redhead girl swears
that she went to school with a girl who
looked just like mei but that girl was
not missing an eye which to them means
that may is the culprit back in koichi's
room blonde haired kid tells him that he
thought that his friend this glasses guy
was the extra student and accidentally
killed him in the process making him
topple over the balcony during an
argument the gang agrees to go check on
him first before anyone else does
something drastic just as they run into
another student bleeding in the hallway
but that's not all koichi then looks in
the dining room and sees the manager in
there brutally stabbed and the room is
on fire they need to get out of there
but just then the rest of the class
comes to check out the ruckus and they
all think that the same person who
stabbed this kid started the fire koichi
then alerts everyone that there's a fire
and they decide to go tell the homeroom
teacher miss makami of what's going on
but she's nowhere to be found just then
this glasses girl appears and claims mei
is the extra person and needs to die she
lunges at may and koichi blocks her
attack redhead girl then explains that
glasses girl found the tape that they
listened to earlier and that she is
emotionally unstable and out of control
and just then they hear the most
terrifying sound glasses girl is on the
speaker and she tells everyone that mei
is the extra person and demands that all
the classmates help in killing mei
glasses girl continues saying that they
both went to the same elementary school
together but now may is suddenly missing
an eye meaning that she was reborn
incomplete glasses girl then tells
everyone that they need to kill mei to
stop the curse and everyone readies
their makeshift weapons with hell this
is a real lord of the flies situation
going on here i love it now the easy
thing would have been to kill me first
obviously to appease the others but let
me ask you what if we kept me alive
since she seems kind of evil and weird
and just like our editor al well in that
case i would have ran downstairs and out
into the forest as we would have had a
better chance of surviving outside than
here or i would have gone into the
kitchen since that's where we'll have
the best chance of finding some weapons
and if i hold up in there making a
makeshift kill corridor where i would
proceed to stab anyone who approached
the doorway and slowly but surely making
my way through all of the kids now the
third option would be more risky but
glasses girl and redhead seem to have
the most influence here so i would
concentrate my efforts on finding
glasses girl first and locate the pda
room where she was held up before
killing her that little [__] and then i
would barricade myself in there and use
the public intercom to blame the whole
situation on glasses girl which was that
glasses girl was emotionally unstable
and that we can't trust her redhead
would most likely be on my side in this
judging by the way she reacted to
glass's girl's statement which would
allow us to save may and not die in the
process the entire school shows up ready
to kill mae but accidentally killed the
homeroom teacher miss mikami in the
process and the duo barely escapes
through the hallway and down the stairs
they are confronted by glasses girl in
the stairway but as they fight glasses
girl gets tangled up by wires and
accidentally dies the mansion then blows
up and kills even more students but then
redhead girl shows up and blames the
death of glasses girl on may herself
forcing mae to run away from koichi to
not put him in further danger outside
the librarian brings out some injured
students while back inside we see this
glasses guy who thinks the dead person
is koichi and attacks him almost killing
him until redhead saves him so she can
kill him for herself but she is stopped
by the librarian who has had enough
killing for one day he then says for
everyone to get out but koichi stays in
desperately looking for may as he runs
around sifting through the burning
rubble and smoke but the battle is not
over as he runs into may but also
redhead girl who truly thinks may is the
dead student and battles koichi who
defends may just long enough until a
massive explosion erupts right in front
of them causing redhead girl to get
impaled by shards of glass on her
deathbed she remembers that she actually
met koichi before that he actually isn't
a new student but one who has been here
for a while but had his memory wiped
after she dies koichi gets a call from
may telling him that she has to stop it
the curse must end she begs kuichi to
not come to her but that doesn't stop
him he reaches may and finds out that
the extra person is none other than the
homeroom teacher miss makami may tells
him that she sees the color of death on
miss makami and that she's known for a
while upon realizing this she also
realizes that she actually witnessed
miss makami's death prior to the school
year with her body being dumped in the
damn they must kill her to stop the
calamity as she is already dead koichi
grabs the pickaxe and readies himself to
kill miss mikami but he suddenly
realizes that his aunt has also been
dead this whole time in shock he finally
strikes the killing blow and sends her
miss makami to the afterlife ending this
curse for good hey guys thank you so
much for checking out this video thank
you and please subscribe hit the thumbs
up button go to the comments section
down below and let us know what you like
what you didn't like and also please
check out our playlist and our social
media